[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we talk about your life your money your
work and your relationships i'm ken
coleman joined by
george campbell as we take you through
your questions this hour the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
how you feeling today i'm doing great
ken welcome back from orlando heard
great things from montre leadership
summit fun time great great group of
people it was a lot of fun and uh the
voice is a little a little weak a little
weak well you did a lot of speaking not
only did you speak at summit but you
interviewed jay leno and nick saban
that's gotta be some career highlights
right it was very fun it couldn't be two
different personalities there right like
jay's mr joke always joking around and
nick saban smiles five times a year i
heard he smiled it was a rare moment i
actually have a picture on this phone
i'll show you on the commercial break
where he actually is smiling incredible
that's gonna be framed in the uh coleman
household just because it's such a rare
occurrence i love it yeah it was big fun
but we are here for you today folks so
george and i gonna team up i'll help you
talk through work issues which are
related to your paycheck and income and
george is here to help you with your
money issues as well we always enjoy
being together so there's uh probably
gonna be some snark and not from me ken
i'm on my best behavior today oh really
i don't know probably not i don't think
so all right let's get to josh who's up
in salt lake city utah josh how can we
help
and uh you know george i'm i'm perfectly
happy to take whatever snark you've got
for me perfect i will deliver be careful
what you ask for josh he is a that that
tongue of his is a weapon so we'll see
how what kind of
yes
i'll be brief in 2020 i was laid off
from my job um but they forgot to
replace me so my client started calling
me and said we still need search engine
optimization do you want to stay on
and
and so i said yeah so i started my own
search engine optimization company and
i've been having a blast
but it's not paying the bills
um
it's almost paying the bills okay let's
stop there for a second okay what are
you charging is it not anywhere near
what the old company was charging or are
you charging the same
i am charging the same um
but probably not enough which is your
question
well no i'm so if you're charging what
the old company did so there's at least
some type of market there and those
people were saying hey this is what we
paid for it before so we're going to
keep paying that now but it's not enough
to cover all of your expenses how much
of a difference is it between your old
paycheck and what you're paying yourself
um
well it's about the same but
but with inflation i'm just having a
hard time paying the new bills what they
used my rent's gone up 30 this year
george what do you have dad
sorry say again do you have any debt
no debt uh baby step three but we're now
making negative progress on baby step 3.
um and you say we is this a spouse
correct okay and they're working outside
the home
yep she's working part-time and i'm
working full-time in this business okay
you have kids
uh not yet but we'd like to start okay
i'm wondering can she go full time you
live off her income as you get this
business off the ground or the other
option is you go work for someone doing
some seo while building this business up
with a client list and contracts and you
figure this thing out
um yes i think it would be easier to
grow the company if instead i did if i
like delivered pizzas in the evenings
okay well i mean there's just so much
remote work you can do with seo and
we've got lots of seo folks here and
people especially business owners are
willing to pay for help with this
because it hurts their brain so you're
in a great spot to do that remotely
and you think that's a better idea than
pizza well i think it's a better idea to
focus on your business than to get a
side hustle if you need the income
and my question is what's have you cut
everything that you can cut this is a
sole
um uh outcome of rent going up and
groceries and gas
is that what you're telling me
yes i mean
yeah there's there's a little bit more
we could cut from the budget but it's
trimming around the edges i do think
it's not how many clients do you have
i have 21 clients right now and is it
recurring revenue
yep monthly retainer okay and you're
saying 21 clients with a monthly
retainer isn't enough to pay the bills
correct that hurts my brain what are you
yeah you know she's charging yeah what's
your retainer
anywhere for the smaller packages are
anywhere from
300 a month up to
you know i've got uh 2 2500 a month
what's your what do you have to cover
what's your what's your all-in budget
you got to cover every month
uh well
i've got i've got a little bit of
overhead in terms of software uh
investments
that's fine but 300 bucks a month times
21 is 6 300 bucks a month yeah tell me
what you're all in budget that's 75k a
year you should be making from this
business with very little expenses
so top line right now is uh nine grand a
month
and of that i take home about 2500 a
month
where's the other money going
uh
software is a big expense um it's sixty
five hundred dollars a month
uh no uh that's about thirteen hundred
dollars a month where's the rest of it
going something's not adding up
link building content creation
um
are you outsourcing this to other people
and paying them
oh you're in the wrong business
right now you're not you can't do it
this way
george he can't yeah you can't 20 you're
paying yourself 2 500 bucks you're
making 30 grand a year from a business
that's making nine ten grand a month
here's what i mean by you're in the
wrong business and i should i should
probably step back a little bit what i
mean is is that the way you're doing
this business is not going to be
sustainable for you you are outsourcing
most of the work
that's not a sustainable model there's
no margin there for you you're
outsourcing most of the work of you of
the nine thousand you're taking in
6 500 of it's going to other people and
others what you're charging needs to
cover those costs and still give you a
great income and so if that means
raising the retainers to 500 instead of
300 and that's your smallest package and
that allows you to have some margin
that's what i'd be doing
yeah you don't think that 20 27 margins
is is good enough
you're telling me you're broke so it
sounds like it's not enough it might be
good enough for somebody else but not
you right now that's my point you can't
ask the question that way it's not a
function of well the margin
margin is 27 it doesn't matter you're
broke
well but i guess the question is do does
my margin percentage need to go up or do
i just need more clients i think both i
think you need to raise your prices get
more clients and figure out how to
outsource this without bleeding yourself
dry what i'm going to do send you a copy
of dave's business playbook entre
leadership that's going to help walk you
through how to do this whole thing
completely debt free with cash how to
lead the teams of the people that you're
leading how to grow this thing in a
sustainable way because i want you to be
a small business owner we love small
business but right now this is not fun
for you and i want it to be yeah yeah
very interesting and one option might be
to go you know what i'm gonna pair this
back a little bit keep it going on the
side and figure out your formulas well
he can go work for someone else
that's what i'm saying go do seo for
somebody else and then
slowly build the side hustle i like that
until you can figure out your margin
your ratios and all that because there's
some
some more work needs to be done here all
right good stuff good question you'll
get there thanks for the call this is
the ramsey show
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell we're here to answer your money
questions your work questions your
relationship questions it's life
and we're held here to help you
get the breakthrough that you need it's
one phone call away it's a free call by
the way triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five george one of the
phenomenons that we've noticed in the
news recently
is the seemingly growing category
of six figure earners who are living
paycheck to paycheck
yeah and i don't think that this is uh
necessarily a new phenomenon right
however it seems to be a growing
phenomenon of okay
i make really good money i've gotten a
raise maybe through the great
resignation them leveling up
and yet they're still living paycheck to
paycheck and what's interesting about it
is when i see things reported on it or
things on social media it's as if it's a
head scratcher
right how could this be oh it must be
all it's inflation right yeah
everybody's excuse now
is inflation it's a great villain to
have but the truth is uh if you have the
mindset that inflation is the is the
enemy and i can never win because of
inflation right you're always you're
always going to have a villain in your
life so we know what else becomes the
villain though before we show this video
is well my my boss isn't in pain me
enough i'm not getting those uh um
inflation-adjusted pay bumps this is a
this is a common theme right now and so
to your point you're always making
somebody else the villain and uh we've
got a video
and uh i really can't wait i've i saw it
i can't wait for george for you to just
break this down well i think our team
just scours the internet looking for
ways to rile us up these days yeah and
they found a video on the internet so
we'll show that video to you and we'll
have some commentary so here it is it's
a tick tock let's watch this
so do you feel like no matter how much
money you make you always seem to be
living paycheck to paycheck well you
might be part of what we call the high
earning poor this is a massive problem
right now that affects millions and
millions of people that make six figures
sometimes multiple six figures and they
don't understand why are they always
living paycheck to paycheck well here's
the deal if you have a job and you get a
raise your average annual raise is about
2.8 percent the odds are you're actually
getting poorer year after year and
doesn't feel like it because you're
getting these raises right but
understand this inflation modest
inflation is three or four percent this
past year it was seven percent and on
top of that your lifestyle tends to
create what we call lifestyle creep your
lifestyle increases too as you make more
money so you combine the fact that your
lifestyle typically gets more expensive
and inflation is eroding the buying
power of the dollar faster than your
raise and you could be making a quarter
million dollars a year and still feel
poor
well this guy must be real fun at
parties ken yeah i gotta say yeah i
think he travels around with his own cue
cards too yes so what do you make of
this is it possible
to be a high earning poor person i don't
buy it well there's a lot of people who
make six figures that are broke yes i'll
say that they're not poor no his death
is he was he was trying to do some word
play there to really i've been haiti
i've been to haiti and seen the most
real poverty impoverished situations
that exist on the planet and i just it
irks me
that that people think they're poor
that's poor isn't their problem
no the problem is they are
in debt deeply in debt have no budget no
financial principles guiding this
paycheck that's coming in every month
and so that is the true problem he's
trying to put in inflation and go it's
never going to be enough guys they're
never going to give you enough raise and
the truth is i looked into this guy he's
got an online course to teach you how to
be successful and do your own be your
own boss kind of thing which is fine i'm
not mad at him for that but what he's
trying to do is
make everyone fearful that they'll never
have enough they'll never make enough to
build wealth to retire with dignity and
that is a hope stealer if i've ever seen
one yeah and it's it's it's so you gotta
so you can't make enough for the man so
you gotta do your own thing and he's the
guy to help yeah and i do think that
there's some emotional
uh manipulation going on when we see
posts like that as if there's just
it's just mystical it feels good to
wallow in the in the pain of it's all
about inflation i'll never get ahead and
part of the goal of our building wealth
live event that you've been a part of is
to give people hope that they can build
wealth in 2022 yeah they can build
wealth regardless of who's in office and
it's a simple concept george i i'm not
going to stay in the money lane very
long but can i hop over into the money
lane come on over water i don't know if
you saw this but one of the grocery
items that is the that has been hit the
hardest by inflation is bacon yes
now i'm just going to tell you something
folks
i love bacon
my boys love bacon i got two teenage
boys you ought to see the amount of
bacon we go through one pack george is
not enough ron swanson levels of bacon
ken this is a lot of bacon we've got two
teenage boys and so i'm gonna tell you
something uh guess what we're not
getting as much bacon please don't tell
me you switched to turkey bacon we've
dialed back on the bacon oh okay you
just dialed back i'm making a simple
point
when cost of goods and services go up
you have to decide how much am i going
to engage in those goods and services
and i've got to cut back i don't just
have to willingly walk into poverty
because it's like well bacon's a lot
more now and i still you know you don't
have to do that yes so on the career
side ken uh you've you're always
encouraging people hey if you're upset
about your current situation go find a
new job yeah it's you can do that you
can go make more money in today's
economy and on the money side the truth
is if you really want to raise do a
budget that's right you don't have to go
beg your boss you can just go get out of
debt come on stick to a proven plan yeah
start investing and then you don't have
to show up to work stressed out because
you feel like you're not making enough
because the truth is we have debt-free
screamers that make 30 grand and they
pay off 16 and they feel freedom and
they're able to live their life there's
also people out there making 200 grand
who are broke because they're bleeding
out heard a debt-free screamer talk
about inflation
not once
it just doesn't seem to they're
inflation-proof so good stuff there yeah
let's get back to the phones john joins
us in chicago john how can we help
hey how you guys doing today good how
can we help today
uh good good so just to give you a
little background information i went to
trade i just turned 20 this month and i
went to trade school about two years ago
i've been an electrician for about a
year
i got this new job basically at an
industrial plant
and i agreed initially just to work
nights 40 hours which i'm happy with but
now they moved it to six days a week and
it's been like this for a month and they
said it's until further notice and last
time they did this about two years ago
from what i hear it lasted about two and
a
half
years and really i don't want to do that
i'm almost debt-free but i know if i
leave there's only other two other
electricians and they're probably gonna
make them work six 12-hour shifts so i'm
gonna feel bad if i leave i just it's a
weird situation i get it and i'm sorry
you're in this situation um
are you getting paid overtime for this
or is it just
i mean yeah they are paying you time but
it's mandatory
yeah it's mandatory there's no question
um how confident are you
in moving um out of there
uh into another electrician's uh company
or whatever with just the i'm assuming
the demand is high for what you do is
that true
yeah yeah so you're pretty confident you
could move to another job and not have
to work those crazy hours correct
pretty much it's just the only thing is
i you know i feel bad i'm about to leave
no no i know i know i'm gonna address
that in a second i'm addressing i'm
addressing your possibilities first
right yeah so you have plenty of options
where you can go make good money maybe
not maybe even a little bit more and not
have to work six days a week true or
false oh yeah yeah true i'd start
looking now if you probably you probably
already have
um but this is a pattern
that they've done before
and there's nothing that would lead me
believe they won't do this again
uh you could certainly bring it up to
them and go hey how much i mean it
sounds like you already have and they
just said this is indefinite which means
don't bother me it is what it is all
right
so
um
you have leverage i would use the
leverage once you have another situation
ready to go and go i can't keep this up
much longer let's just find out where
they really are second thing you do not
need to feel guilty about leaving
it is your life
you are not doing anything unethical
you are not doing anything that is
a jerk move by taking care of yourself
and doing what is best for you is that a
true statement or a false statement in
your mind
uh no no that's that's a true statement
i agree well listen man
your buddies can leave too
yeah if they can't they can't or if they
don't believe they can't then they won't
but the reality is is you don't stay in
an unsavory situation an unfortunate
situation a soul-sucking situation just
because you feel bad for the people that
are going to stay on the ship if the
ship is sinking and this is an emotional
ship that is sinking for you you got to
get off the boat true or false
true very true then get off the boat and
don't look back
because here's the deal if you were to
stay there just because of these really
cool guys that you like guess what
happens
you'll eventually resent them because
you're going to make them the reason
that you didn't leave and that's garbage
thinking it's stinking thinking stop go
do what's best for you
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsey show thrilled to have you with us
as we talk about your life your money
your work your relationships one phone
call
at a time
thrilled to have you with us george
campbell is with me as we take your
phone calls
and we're thrilled that uh you have
decided to join us and anytime here if
someone's listening and you've got a
question pops up maybe uh from one of
our other callers jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two
five let's go to moorfield west virginia
alex is there alex how can we help
hi thank you for taking my call
so i'm 19 years old and i have more debt
than i would really like to have and
i honestly it kind of feels like a
pretty heavy weight and i just want to
know what my steps should be as far as i
some of the things are valuable and i
feel like i can i can get my way out of
this and never get back into this and so
i just
uh i just i guess wanted to talk to the
people who know best so alex riddle me
this how much debt would you like to
have
none
perfect answer okay that i just needed
to know the level before we continue
that helps me
okay so 50 how much debt do you have
total
fifty eight thousand dollars wow what
kind of debt
okay so i have twenty two thousand nine
hundred dollars debt and a new truck
i have
twenty four thousand eight hundred
dollars debt and a john deere tractor
and then i have seven thousand six
hundred dollars debt and some
landscaping equipment that i do uh for a
side hustle with my neighbor we have
some equipment together and then i have
a personal loan for two thousand seven
hundred dollars that is just leftover
negative equity from where i've already
sold out of a lot of debt hmm
are you in like uh are you in business
with this john deere tractor is this
just a big toy
okay well essentially it's become a big
toy because i've been fortunate enough
to get a really good job i work from
home in the retirement industry and i
love it and i'm kind of getting out of
out of these these smaller things
because it wasn't really panning out it
wasn't it wasn't bringing in what i was
sending out for it is the tractor are
you upside down in the tractor or is it
still worth more than what you owe on it
or worth the same
it is worth about the same with plus or
minus fifteen hundred dollars so
manageable sweet so how much do you make
um so with my new job i make about forty
eight thousand uh
as i say i have some other income coming
in from the side hustle that my neighbor
and i do landscaping stuff with
essentially lawn mowers not related to
the tractor okay what's the truck worth
the truck is worth a little better than
60 000. what the truck is worth 60k and
you owe 22.
yes sir i it's okay i'm very passionate
about vehicles it's a truck that i've
saved a lot through my childhood and a
lot through
my first working years and i put a ton
of money i knew better than to go into
debt i did it anyways i've put a ton of
money down and i've put everything i've
made this year from both jobs on it
trying to knock it out because it's like
five point four percent interest and
watching as a cure every day is killing
me hey alex alex if we want to talk
about interest you're on the wrong show
man i'm trying to help you become debt
free that's what i'm passionate about
sell it
so here's the deal the truck is gone
today the tractor is gone today you're
debt free today
and some some money left over and some
money left over which is going to become
your emergency fund because i assume you
don't have a lot in savings
i do how much do you have
about 13 000.
okay
well you won't have to touch that 13
that will become your emergency fund if
you do all these things now the question
is are you willing to sell the truck in
the tractor today
to be debt free
yes are you willing to pay the price
that certainly sounds like what i need
to do are there other trucks out there
are there other pieces of metal on
wheels that you could love one day
certainly are that's what i figured and
can we do it all with cash going forward
and any side hustles we do we do with
cash going forward
yes how about the landscaping equipment
can you sell that
i can do you need it because it sounds
like the side hustle is not panning out
versus the 8 000 debt you have on the
equipment uh
yeah i can sell it and i think that
would be my best bet it's a good move
because if you want to keep messing
around on the side hustle with the
landscaping job that's fine but you can
rent the equipment you build that into
your job
you know renting that equipment is very
affordable if that's something you want
to continue to do i would sell all of
those things man now you're debt free
you've got a nice emergency fund you can
still buy a decent truck
so what would you suggest them as far as
a vehicle
a decent truck with what we can afford
you make 48k
and our rule of thumb is everything with
a motor and it doesn't add up to more
than half of your annual income which
means everything with a motor in it that
you own shouldn't add up to more than 24
thousand dollars
so if i'm you i'm if whatever cash you
have left over that's not your emergency
fund leave that at three to six months
of expenses outside of that get a
reasonable truck for 15 20 grand that's
what i'm doing if i'm in your shoes
i understand
now the question is are you gonna go
back into debt for some other you know
hair brained idea down the road
no no that won't happen i'm already
working on how i wanted to go about
getting out of this debt and saving up
to purchase some property up front with
cash and whoa
you're very ambitious and i like this
and keep in mind you can always buy a
used tractor if you're just putting
around on the tractor with a car i don't
even
i don't even think i need it i think
looking at it now it was just a mistake
yes of course well it's all right you
paid a stupid tax but the truth is you
can reverse all of this very easily
right now because of the market and uh
because of them being vehicles and
tractors wow so i'm undoing this thing
asap man and once you you're out of debt
with a pile of cash never look back
never touch dead again at 19 you're
gonna be unbelievably wealthy if you do
that thank you for the call alex yeah i
got to tell you something you may be
surprised by this
i've always wanted a john deere tractor
really yeah is it what does it use for
it at all is it a brand association
thing i i think the idea of you know
like uh you know late late summer
evening
cutting the lawn listening to something
well no one mentions kind of moving
along unless it's a john deere then you
go to john deere tractor otherwise you
just call it a tractor yeah it's a great
country song i think by joe diffy john
deere green if i'm not mistaken for
cutting do you want to sing it for us or
is that going to get us taken off the
air um well kelly's singing it behind
the glass it kind of goes boy uh maybe i
need to get the melody in my head
but in john deere green on a hot summer
night
uh something something something i can't
remember that's all we can do legally on
air thank you ken for that beautiful oh
see you were setting me up see there's
licensing issues i can't even sing i
don't know i just wanted to hear you
sing it makes me happy but you know
what's interesting about this is
um
george there's a psychology involved
in selling
something that you really like that's
really shiny and i heard it in his voice
and and there's nothing wrong with alex
he's just like the rest of us i want you
to address that because in his situation
um the
landscaping equipment the tractor
and the truck he can eliminate all of
those debts by simply selling them boy
that's an easy way out it's not always
that easy he's lucky in that those still
have some value but there is something
like tell your student loan
sorry
so what's he gonna face when he he gets
off the phone and he now starts figuring
out what's he going to be facing uh well
first is going to be the emotional
decision of letting these pieces go that
were a toy that probably a lot of people
justify this because they got well it's
part of the side hustle account i need
this for my job yeah i need a 60 000
truck for my job i've got to have the
tractor because the side hose is making
400 bucks a month right that's good
money right even though i'm 30 000 in
debt on the equipment so part of it is
emotional the next step is what are the
tactical pieces now where can i get the
best price i need to take good photos
clean this up sell it on you know
facebook marketplace i don't know where
you sell i'm guessing facebook
marketplace is the best place for
tractors these days yeah i don't know
who knows i don't know but those are the
pieces that is next for him are the
tactical once he deals with the
emotional yeah but once he does that and
those checks clear
there's going to be such freedom and see
that's the key right there you got to
focus on what's on the other side of
this because here's the deal he's
driving a sweet truck
just by the sheer cost the next truck he
gets is going to feel so oh
comparatively yeah it's like the ugly
duckling you know it just is wonderful
when you drive crappy cars your whole
life and you finally upgrade
my 2013 feels like a maserati brand new
off the lot right now oh yeah and it's
because i drove terrible cars my whole
life what did you just upgrade from uh
honda civic 09 09 a honda civic 2013
tesla you feel like you're in a space
you're only four years older yeah
the technology can i tell them kelly go
ahead kelly bought my old car for her
son who is about to take his driving
test george didn't sell you a lemon did
he kelly no it's a great it's a honda
man i think things will run forever we
had it checked
checked out and everything and it's a
great car
integrity all right so here's the deal
folks
short-term pain on selling those really
fun toys long-term gains but long-term
gain way to go george great advice alex
thank you for the call you're just a
couple transactions away from financial
peace do it
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me in
studio
our question of the day
comes from blinds.com blinds.com is 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure pick the wrong color they'll
remake your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more make sure that you use the
promo code ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from mckenna in
oregon my husband and i are in our early
twenties he earns 90k a year and i make
45. i also have a side business in the
wedding industry that brings in between
25 and 30 a year we're debt free have an
emergency fund and are half over halfway
to saving our twenty percent home down
payment i hate my job and would love to
pursue my own business full time because
i know i can make it grow quickly to
replace my salary the problem is that my
husband's job doesn't provide health
insurance so we'd have to be
self-insured if i quit to complicate
things we'd like to try for a baby this
year and once we have children i plan to
quit working entirely should i quit the
job i hate so i can focus on my personal
business and lose our insurance or do i
just suck it up so we can save as much
as we can and try to juggle both jobs
until a baby comes wow george now this
question is loaded a lot going on a lot
of layers
uh well mckenna i got to tell you
if i read this correctly
um that once you do have babies you are
going to be a full-time mama meaning
that the business that you're talking
about potentially starting is going to
go away
i just wouldn't start a business that
i'm going to eventually close down
i would work in the job i know you can't
stand your job and that stinks
so either change jobs change locations
and keep letting someone else pay you
uh is probably the best route just
overall i don't think there's a wrong
decision if you want to hustle because
here's the thing george you know there's
no guarantee that just because we start
trying to have a baby that we're gonna
have a baby true and that could be i
hope it's a quick process but it could
be two years three years took stacey and
i seven years i mean so we have to plan
for the future act towards the future
but then
make decisions that are best for us in
the present i agree and uh i think
replacing the job she hates is
absolutely a must
it's just the issue of do i start it on
my own and we don't have health care and
then our our costs are increasing when
you self-fund health care and
i don't mean to take anything away from
her her discourage her but it does it's
not as easy as she makes it sound to
just start that business and replacing
her salary so a lot of financial risks
that could affect the ability to have
the baby so my advice is probably to
consider same type of work making the
same money she's making now or more
in a place that she doesn't
hate or replace the job altogether maybe
it's the work maybe it's the location
the environment the culture maybe it's
both that's what i would do i would not
take on the added stress
of starting a business to try to replace
your current income
and
increasing your health care costs i
wouldn't go that direction agreed and
the other option is maybe the husband
can go find a job making 90 or more that
has those benefits
and then she can quit stick to her side
hustle baby comes and we're all good so
that's another option too good yeah
that's a very good option there george
absolutely love that but thank you for
the question mckenna
russell now joins us in phoenix arizona
russell how can we help
well yeah uh how you guys doing we're
having a blast what's going on with you
uh so a quick um funny story uh when you
were trying to sing in the last segment
i'm actually a voice teacher
oh well no i want to point out that
i wish i was on the phone now yeah but i
didn't try to sing there was no there
was no attempt at all i actually held
back because i needed to work the melody
out in my head but i do appreciate that
you're available in case i decide to do
that after the end of your question
thanks for the disclaimer yes
no so the reason i was calling was
so i'm just starting my journey on
uh the baby steps and uh because i've
been listening to the show for a few
weeks and finally you know gone the
website and
said you know it's time to do this so
um at this point um my my base step one
with the emergency fund and i got the uh
every dollar wrap to start creating my
budget
uh which i've never done before
my wife and i so i can be pretty new
but um
as i was doing this process i've been
creating
gathering all of our debts and all that
all of our things
and trying to and just getting ready for
the snowball once we get our emergency
fund
and the question i have for you guys is
um my car loans
so i've heard you know i'm just gonna
show you you know try to sell the cars
off you know get rid of that if possible
but unfortunately on my car loans
all of them i am too far negative
to be able to cover the negative is just
outright seldom so my question
is
on the snowball usually going smallest
to largest
if i know i need to pay an additional
eight grand off my car
where i can break even
should i move the car up
to an eight thousand dollar instead if i
owe eighteen thousand so if i start
moving up to an eight thousand dollar in
my snowball to pay that off and then
sell it to get rid of that debt instead
of leaving the eighteen 000 car run
lower on the snowball
hmm based on what you told me it doesn't
sound like that makes the most sense
what are the cars worth
okay so
um
there's three cars
so the the smallest one which i owe 18
is worth about 10.
okay
the next one
i owe 32
and it's probably worth about 24.
all right
and then the biggest one
i o 60
that's probably worth 50.
what's your household income
take home is right under a hundred
thousand a year
what's the gross on that
probably 130 i don't know somewhere
around there yeah you have a hundred and
ten thousand dollars in car loans which
is more than you make in a year and our
rule of thumb is to have all that add up
to no more than half of your annual
income and so
we have to get rid of these cars
regardless i'm gonna do the lesser of
the evils here could you sell the 61 for
50
and make up the difference because
that's the biggest one anyways
i don't have the ten thou i don't have
the negative to cover at this point no
so we the only time we tell people it's
okay to go get you know a loan from a
credit union or local bank is when
they're under water in a car like this
now i don't want you to go rack up
another 30 grand in personal loans and
just move the debt around but if we can
get rid of these cars and then have a
much smaller loan to face i'm okay with
that
that was my thinking as well i just want
to kind of confirm um if that should be
a good option to go that route the
question is how are you this far
underwater with a car market like we
have right now
uh bad impulsive decisions on my wife
and my decisions uh
like that newest one that 60 000 cargo
we just just got that probably a few
months back before i started listening
to the ramsey show and in a few months
it's already appreciated that much
it's already depreciated that much in a
few months
well yeah well they marked it up pretty
i didn't realize how much you marked it
up so i wasn't feeling
what they were doing
and why do you guys need three cars do
you have three drivers
no again with the three car thing
uh
bad decision
my wife was impulsive while wanting a
third car because she won't put a bunch
of miles on her car
and she regrets it now is but yeah she
got in the idea that she could afford a
small payment and not put so many miles
on her car since she drives so far to
work
so unfortunately we have three cars okay
what other debt do you have
um we've got
credit cards so credit cards probably
maybe 11 to 12 grand worth
student loans
it's about 18 000
and then a solar loan for 40 000 oh boy
okay
i'm gonna put you guys through financial
peace university on us it's our gift to
you uh that's all part of ramsey plus
including every dollar premium you said
you just started your first every dollar
budget and so what i want you to do is
watch the lessons with your wife have a
conversation after each lesson with
takeaways an action plan do the every
dollar premium budget which is going to
connect to your bank account this is an
emergency situation
this is not like ah yeah we're going to
do the debt this is we don't see
a restaurant we don't see a
drive-through this is rice and beans
this is cutting every expense possible
you guys have been living la vita loca
and uh it's time to stop and be adults
so we're rooting for you i hope this
gift helps so hang on austin's gonna
pick up we'll get you plugged into that
yeah all of a sudden i've got ricky
martin in my own boys all i can do to
keep my shoulders still
but but i gotta keep my shoulders down
with a voice teacher on the line george
campbell thanks pal for hanging out
thanks to our team behind the glass and
you america this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk to you about your life
your money your work and your
relationships i'm ken coleman
joined by george campbell we are ramsey
personalities and we are here for you
this hour it is a free phone call to
jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number triple a eight
two five
five two two five how's your energy
george you ready i'm making i got some
cold brew under the table i've been
taking some sips off of cold brew under
the table yeah coffee let me make sure
people know because here's the i don't
know it sounded very very bougie as the
kids like to say it's just iced coffee
yeah i need to try some of that on the
next break i tried to get a little one
time and you didn't you weren't a big
fan i'm not a big fan i like a little
cream it's an acquired taste all right
i'll go with black coffee well we are
here we are fully caffeinated apparently
ready for you let's go to the phones
chris joins us in oklahoma city oklahoma
chris how can we help
hey uh i take good money here can see
ricky martin but uh my main question yes
get in line man start the kickstarter
i'm on it my main question is my wife
just changed jobs um so she's
transferring over 401k we're trying to
decide what to do with that okay um the
options are if she keeps it at
nationwide right now um it's not taxed
because it's a pretext 401k but if you
rolls it over to her current one it's a
roth 401k and they'll tax it now but i'm
assuming that's not going to be taxed
when you retire so we're wondering what
to do with that
uh do you guys have a paid for house
no we do not okay i would just roll it
over to an ira
a direct rollover to a traditional ira
that way you won't have any tax
implications it's not worth taking the
tax hit right now because that money is
better spent helping you guys along the
baby steps so we tell people not to do
those transfers to convert that money
and take the tax it unless they're in
baby step seven with a paid for house
okay so you don't need to transfer to
the new job yeah you can transfer it to
an ira outside of her work that's that's
where she's gonna have the most control
over it you're gonna have the most
options for investing as well a
smartvestor pro can do that you can
reach out to one at ramseysolutions.com
uh to get that process done easy thank
you for the call chris all right lauren
is up next st louis from missouri lauren
how can we help
hi um so i have a quick question for you
um my husband and i are wondering if we
should sell our jeep we're currently in
baby step number two
okay how much do you owe on the jeep
um it's we own it so we own both of our
vehicles we only have 4 700 left in debt
and we'll be out of that next month oh
yeah so why would you sell it
so um we can we have opportunity to make
we both work from home so we only drive
my car now pretty much we haven't driven
the jeep in
about a year um so we can actually make
around twelve thousand dollars off of it
more than you paid for it
yes more than one page
wow
okay and it would move us from baby step
two
to baby step 3b immediately basically
but we did get an offer that was a few
thousand less than what we asked for so
we're wondering are we just being really
impatient
i think you are there's nothing wrong
with selling the jeep but you don't have
to and there's nothing about the
situation where i go oh my gosh you got
to sell the car today
so if you want to hang on to it if you
like the car keep the car and you'll get
there you know
it may take another six months to get to
baby step 3b i imagine right
um we should be out in baby step 3b by
august
okay so you're going to get out of debt
in the next month and then
a month or two later have a fully funded
emergency fund yeah yeah wow what's your
income
um we make uh before
taxes 147.
that's fantastic
well that's great news yeah the only
question i have lauren just from a
practical standpoint i absolutely
understand where you're coming from
makes a lot of sense on some level
because you both work from home but you
know give you an example my i had a flat
tire this morning
mm-hmm yeah little screwdriver
yeah get out of the garage get out in
the garage the tires flat i'm like
underneath the car what the world so
sometimes you might need that second car
and you guys have got a paid for jeep
that's the reason to have you know
something you know around and if you
sold the jeep at least have a five
thousand dollar car that if if one of
your cars had to be in the shop you
could get around but i mean there's
nothing wrong with selling the jeep
either but i wouldn't sell it for less
than what you think you can get for it
regardless of whether you sell or not
okay yeah i would be patient to get the
profit that you're looking for on it but
again three months from now i mean it's
a wash either way and so i wouldn't sell
it out of impatience i would sell it
because you go hey 3b is way more
important than us having this jeep we're
okay buying a beater for now yeah i'm
good with that yeah i like that good job
love the call lauren you guys are gonna
be debt free hopefully we get to hear
your scream here on the show
really really exciting stuff let's go to
san bernardino california sarah is there
sarah how can we help
hi
um so i have a job question i have an
interview on tuesday
for a different position in the same
company
um i want to be professional while
asking for a raise into this new
position
and also kind of i don't know
guaranteeing or give me some sort of
acknowledgement that i have licensing
that i'm finishing up in the next couple
of months
that there will be an option for a raise
when i actually get that license in the
next few months
so
what do you know about this position
does it already come with a raise
uh or is it do you know where it falls
in the you know as it relates to what
you're currently making
um
so i've had this position before and i
left the company hated the other job and
came back okay i
took a pay cut when i came back
for the new position
and from what i was making previously in
the same position
it is a travel position so
i know that i'll be working different
hours i know that i'll be
driving um quite a lot but they pay
mileage and stuff like that so
it'll be a raise in a couple of
different areas
but
when i was there originally i was at
like 1950 and i
pretty much want to say like i don't
want to go in
into this
is such a big change without less than
20. okay but you're currently making
1950 or that's what you made previously
that's what i made previously i'm
currently at 17.50 right but this job is
going to pay more is what you basically
just told me roundabout way
this new position pays more so i
wouldn't go in asking for a raise with
the job that that is not going to go
over well no matter how sweet and kind
and smooth you say it
you go in and you try to win the job
what i would say in the interview is
that you are very close to completing uh
some additional licensing or
certifications and stuff like that does
that make sense i would tell them hey i
am because i'm assuming that's relevant
to this new job correct
yes yeah i'd let him know that but i
wouldn't do the old hey i really want
the job here's why i think i'm a good
fit blah blah blah and by the way i'm uh
i'm almost done with this additional
training
and i would like to have a raise once
that's done i don't think that's the
right way to go about it but i do think
it makes sense for you to share that you
are about ready to complete this
training
and what i would say in the same
sentence is
is there a growth plan if you get in
this position to where there are
measured results
that will be agreed upon between me and
you
and i can go after that with this new
training so that i can continue to grow
in my value and responsibility the
company and of course win financially as
well it's all a posture george yeah it's
all about how you set that up that's
good you've got a lot of resources about
this very issue on your website that's
right ken coleman dot com knows how to
ask for a raise is an article with a lot
of other great resources as well all
right quick break and then when we come
back more of your questions this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman george campbell joining me here
uh boy when it comes to events we are
back at it aren't we george on the road
again on the road
yeah uh you know let's talk about our
building wealth live event uh we were
just in orlando florida last week great
crowd 3 000 people yeah just fired up
just really really fun stuff uh and at
this event we're going to walk you
through the steps to build real and
lasting wealth the financial principles
we teach at that event are the only
principles that do work we have decades
to prove it the building wealth live
tour has already had two great stops
vegas and orlando and we've got some
fall dates george i don't even know if
you have these on your calendar they're
not there yet you can get your phone out
okay while i go through these okay just
just just uh just get them out phoenix
september 13th sacramento november 1st
minneapolis november 10th san antonio
november 15th dave ramsey rachel cruz
george campbell dr john delaney and i
will all be there tickets start at 25 or
you get a four pack of tickets starting
at 60
bring your friends uh friends rather not
finns uh friends go to
ramseysolutions.com
events ramseysolutions.com events and
then
how about our entree leadership summit
just finished that up that is our
premier leadership event for leaders of
all levels if you want to grow in your
leadership entre leadership summit it'll
be may 30th through june 2nd
2023
in nashville i can't even believe i'm
talking about 2023 it's the future uh
along with dave ramsey myself dr john
delonay you'll hear from james clear of
the atomic habits phenomena
willie robertson of duck dynasty george
that was one of your favorite shows
wasn't it
so good yeah unbelievable how much
george loves to binge on duck dynasty uh
he's got a terrible duck i've always
wanted to live yeah you've got some duck
waiters that are taller than you and the
whistle and you have the the
is it a whistle i don't know what they
call i think it's a duck call well yeah
it's not a whistle okay uh dr jordan
peterson oh that's more your taste uh
patrick lencioni amy cuddy mark king and
monique
oh yeah she's fantastic from the food
network this event is a game changer for
leaders so uh ramsay solutions.com
summit for that one for amazing
solutions.com summit so there you go
lots of events
best way to figure it out ramsey
solutions.com hit the old event page and
we just have scores and scores of things
for you so fun stuff can't wait to be
back
yeah let's go to grand rapids uh
minnesota actually amy is there amy how
can we help
hi hi amy
how you doing are you surprised to be
with us
amy you're live on the air the whole
show is about you right now
wow yeah okay
um my question is my husband and i were
through the baby
steps and we have about 200 000 invested
already
but we also have
we also own a business and we're
considering
the question is whether we should sell
the business now or not it has quite a
high valuation to it so if we could get
that price we were considering selling
it now investing the sales
from the business
and then we would just cash flow
doing other jobs or something for the
next few years
or whether we should keep the business
work on it for a few years and then
retire in say five years or so and sell
it at that point
what would keep you
from selling it today let's say that we
we got the offer the valuation matches
up
what would keep you from going ahead and
moving it versus staying with it for
five more years is it to make even more
five years from now
what's the choice here emotionally for
you too
um
i think it's
more of a sense of security if we kept
it and the cash flow
that we would hopefully get from i mean
nobody can predict the economy but
hopefully it would bring the cash flow
it has been up to this point what's the
current production security in that
um well on
paper about 250 000 a year
and in reality is it different well
no i shouldn't say that we invest much
of it back into the business so we're
probably taking about 150. okay so your
income is 150 the business revenue is is
higher yeah have you officially started
shopping it
no wait we haven't listed it or anything
that's the decision we're trying to make
what's the number what's the number you
think you're going to sell it for what
would make you guys go no-brainer we're
done let's go what's the number
uh no less than one million it's valued
at
currently at like 1.2 maybe 1.4
depending who valued it
we had a business valuation done um by a
company who's who sells business what
business are you on
we make a product and then we sell it
all online okay um do you anticipate
having to work in the business as a part
of the deal or do you think you would be
able to sell it and be able to walk no
attachment
i would want to walk
got it
well you might want to but you may not
get an offering a lot of times in
situations like this certainly when you
start a company like this you are the
founders
so i would certainly weigh that
um but i don't know that there's any i
think george this is a numbers game
let's say you get 1.25 1.25 or whatever
you said it was amy for it now you know
waiting five years how much more does
the valuation go up that's going to be a
direct
result of what your revenues are
and you know do you get halfway through
two and a half years in going man we're
tired we just want to kind of do
something else i think it's a numbers
game because i don't think it's going to
be that much more security george you
agree well you're saying amy that the
cash flow yearly is the security you're
looking for
so you're saying if we sold it we
wouldn't have an income anymore
well we would but we don't think we
would make that much
like we would both work my husband
worked full-time
and i would i would either we would
either buy another smaller business that
i could work at or i'd just get a job
okay and you're okay with that it sounds
like you're you don't really want to
continue the business you're not in love
with it
i'm not in love with it but it either
way i'm i'm good with it i mean i have
plans for it if i kept it what would
your husband do
i actually have i want to push back on
something if i might and i might not be
able to
how about what would your husband do
give me an example of a job that he or
you would do for somebody else
if you sold this
well he already worked full time he
would continue with his job all right
what is that job
uh he works for a supermarket
how much does he make
uh
his boy
he makes like 13 an hour
okay i just challenged the notion that
the two of you in this world with the
experience that you have couldn't make
close to 125 000 and you don't even need
that much but if you sold the business
um
and you this business is on the side
is that right from what your husband
does you're the one running it
i'm running it but it's our main source
of income yeah no questions we invest my
husband right
when you say you invest are you
investing back into the business or are
you saying into the stock market
no i didn't stop my day okay wendy how
old are you two
i'm 40. he's 44. okay so you guys have
plenty of life to go so i'm going to
make decisions based on our long-term
desired future that we have together and
so if selling the business helps you get
there then i'm all for it but right now
it doesn't sound like you guys have a
clear picture of what's next
and i think having that clear picture
would help you make a decision
okay are you both on the same page as
you call us today or is one of you
leaning one way and one's leaning the
other
we're both going back and forth we've
had much discussion over this
when you called today when you called
today which way were you leaning sell or
keep
sell which way was he leaning when you
called
i think he's leaning towards cell at the
moment
okay well i think george is right then i
think that i think that you know you've
got some real options here i love that
you have the options but this is
where do we want to be five years 10
years 15 years down the road i'd start
there yeah do we want to retire early do
we want to be business owners long term
and the truth is if you got a million
dollars out of this deal and you
invested that money and you made 10 on
that money that's a hundred grand a year
you made on your investment without
running a business exactly and then you
can work for fun
uh work for dreams
i think this is a candlelight dinner
where do we want to be 15 20 years from
now now once we agree on that what
decision do we make primarily around
this business
based on where we want to be
and i love your options
don't stress over this just get really
really clear and watch what happens when
we get clear we get amazing confidence
on the other side of clarity this is the
ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
all right america welcome back to the
ramsay show where we help you win with
your money
your work and your relationships
i'm ken coleman joined by george
campbell thrilled to have you with us if
you want to jump in it's a free call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five anthony is now on the
line in houston texas anthony how can we
help
hey sir good afternoon good afternoon
how you doing oh we're having a blast
all right so
i have a couple of questions for you
today first is
we are very familiar with the
baby steps program but we didn't follow
it
all through our journey
so um
we skipped the um the step two
but um
we
we we are in a great position now
because we are in debt for like maybe 60
grand but now we are down to maybe 9
000. wow great job yeah
because we did a lot of side hustle and
overtime and
right now my question is we have
approximately 20 000 on our savings for
our emergency fund
and we still have i think 9 000
in debt combined
with our car
and one credit card
okay what's the problem
should
i pay that off yes
and use my emergency fund yeah for it
and then yes because the baby steps are
pretty clear you understand the baby
steps as we lay them out yes
okay well then you've just gotten it out
of order the great news is
uh you got the money and you're
debt-free today like you could do it
while we're on the phone man what are we
waiting on let's go
right okay
yeah and another question that i have is
um right now
we are we are here in houston and um we
are thinking of moving to california
um is it
wise to do that um why are you thinking
but i don't want to be snarky right now
i'm trying to suppress the snark because
i need to know what the real reason is
why are you thinking about moving to
california
um i believe that um
it's just like
like a better spot for our family we had
a vacation over there a couple of times
and we love the area um
what's specifically about california and
its taxes
and its draconian policies
and i'm being serious are better for you
and your family than houston i mean
specifically give me three things that
make it better other than we had a great
vacation
first my wife and i are in the medical
field and they pay more over there right
but everything else costs more too
that's right that's right and um
the the lake tahoe we really love and
the vacation we have a
couple of family members that lives
there and we just want to stay close to
family okay so so you asked us you asked
george and i if that's a good decision
uh yeah i'm i'm trying to see where the
numbers make sense were you wondering or
do you absolutely believe it's a good
decision
because this is a numbers question i
mean
to live there and to ask is it a good
decision you're saying okay financially
does this make sense and it's it's all
about the budget the increased cost of
living yes you're making more money so
which way were you leaning
um we are
leaning
towards moving there
okay you got jobs lined up
not yet
okay george yeah i mean to ken's point i
think you have a lot of homework to do
to actually figure out is this life
going to be the life we thought it was
because what i'm worried about is you
get out there and you go hey we're
making more money but we have less at
the end of the month and we're not as
happy as we thought and man this is
tough so i want you to do your research
to actually figure out okay if we made
15 grand more with the cost of living
increase does that actually mean any
more in our budget every month because
it may not
i mean anthony i'm gonna square with you
i've got
really good friends that have moved from
california
to tennessee recently
and really good friends that are
considering it and we're talking about a
massive
pay raise for them by moving here and
the tax breaks so i wouldn't do it for
the pay raise
the pay raise is you've got to run it
out like george said what are our what's
our taxable income what's that going to
look like what what's the tax burden
the cost of living and all those places
you got to do your homework and lay it
out on the budget you know and you look
you called and you were doing the baby
steps out of order please don't make a
move on this just because we had a
wonderful time of vacation there if
anything else i'd go spend another week
or two there and really get on the
ground and look at housing and really
talk to a great real estate pro maybe
from ramseysolutions.com and get an idea
of what things are going to look like
you need a lot of information as to
whether or not this is a good financial
move or not
okay
got it because i'm with you lake tahoe
area is gorgeous it's fantastic i'm not
against moving anywhere if you want to
move there oh it's your prerogative but
just don't do it for the wrong reasons
with you know false expectations i don't
want that for you and on the baby step
side you're going to fully fund that
emergency fund as soon as that debt's
paid off today we're going to build it
back up to where you need it to be for
three to six months of expenses and
begin investing thank you though for the
call anthony appreciate it cara is up
next sacramento california kara how can
we help
hi there um my husband and i are
considering buying an automotive shop in
the small town we live
and he is currently the foreman at the
shop and our jobs basically would be
to both have our full-time jobs be
running this shop and i do
administrative and accounting so i would
be doing that side of it
and we're just wondering if we should
really dig into this and keep looking
into options and moving forward they
want
150k for the business
that doesn't include a building or
anything that's just the employees and a
lot of the tools
and would you be picking up a lease on
the building or what would the building
cost be
so the lease right now is 2600 a month
and his the current owner's lease was up
in about a year so we'd have to
get something solid you know to see what
our lease would be beyond that year
what's the business worth
so
that's one thing i really want to
dig into the accounting if we get more
serious about it his
kind of loosey-goosey um
income before he gets paid is 250k a
year
yeah you got to dig in the books and i'm
glad you have an accounting background
because look bottom line is we're
looking at we're looking at gross and
we're looking at net okay
yeah and you understand what valuations
are built on correct
yes and we definitely if that 150 k is
um more than three years worth of profit
that's definitely not what it's worth
then we definitely will not pay it
that's exactly and are you going to do
this with cash do you have 150k laying
around
so we don't have 150k laying around he
is willing to do payments kind of like
how dave
recommends the profit out of the
business for about half of it we
would try to come up with the other half
we have about
8 000 extra right now and we have some
like uh lawsuit settlements that would
hopefully be coming in
before then and we have a couple toys we
can sell too my guess is it's not worth
150 though so that's the good news i
don't think it's going to be worth 150
once you dig in doesn't sound like to me
okay
um maybe it is i don't know uh but i i
doubt it why are they selling the
business
so the owner is retirement age and he
just wants to retire okay
yeah well i don't think it's a bad idea
if the valuation comes through and you
go this is a good buy and they're
willing to do the deal and we can pay it
over the you know through the profit of
the business
and you guys want to be business owners
and it must be also reasonable cara on
what your what percentage of the profits
you're paying each month you know what i
mean
yeah definitely you got to pay
yourselves my husband
yeah we need to pay ourselves and we
need to you know have some cash in there
so we don't end up
not being like payroll is that a
valuation that dave uses is that still
that's correct applicable absolutely
absolutely okay yeah and then if we did
get the opportunity to buy the um
building what would be the guidelines on
that because i know mortgage is 15 year
25 of your take home
well i think if you can afford it as
part of the business um and that becomes
you know the business debt you work on
paying off it becomes a different
situation
thank you though for the call eyes wide
open
let's not feel like this is the only way
that we can do what we want to do don't
get sucked in if this doesn't feel right
trust your gut and walk away
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by george campbell this
hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to jump in triple
eight eight two five
lori is up in springfield missouri lori
how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up i am
so my parents and my husband and myself
we have 529s for our kiddos
my parents had donated quite a bit of
money so
over the years to it and
my middle kiddo graduated last year
but ended up going into the military
so
he had about 18
000
who wasn't a great big 529 so just about
18 000
in his account but this first quarter of
the year he's taken about a three
thousand dollar hit so his plans are
he's going to do four years in the
military he's currently stationed
overseas he's going to do about four
years in the military come back out go
into the reserves
use all of his military benefits to go
back to school when he gets home so my
question for you is as the market
plummets
and he's you know kind of we have it in
the most conservative
form we can
should we continue just to roll with it
and keep it there for the next four
years and see what happens or should we
pull it
pay the taxes
and the fees which will may or may not
be less than
what he's going to lose in the market
and wait for him to get home in some
other you know
in a savings account or something like
that
i would not do the latter i would not
take the tax hit to take this money out
i would just leave it in there allow it
to continue to grow you can always
change the beneficiary to someone else i
mean it could be a grandchild this can
be way down the line yeah you can use
the money to pay down student loans um
and so there's a lot of options you have
it can be used for anyone in the family
so i would hang on to that i would not
take the tax hit and there's a lot of
things you can use it on for expenses uh
even if you know i don't know what does
does military will that cover everything
from laptops housing well
well it'll give him yeah it will give
him housing he'll get a housing stipend
when my husband did it he got a check
every month that was went to pay for
you know
housing costs and those kind of things
laptop not so much
um he does have right now he's
he's um doing a whole lot better than
his dad and i did he's putting about
fifteen hundred dollars a month into a
savings account like shoving that in so
yeah he's doing a really great job i'd
leave it in there there's a lot of
qualified education expenses you can use
it on you can always change the
beneficiary but it's not worth it to
take the tax hit on this
even if it's like losing money just
you're not losing money by leaving it in
yeah it's only a loss when you take it
out you gotta ride the roller coaster
gotcha
write it okay i would keep it investing
i would not leave it on the cash side i
would leave that money invested the
market's going to come back that money
is going to grow and it can be used down
the line yeah thank you so much for the
call jackson tennessee shannon is up
shannon how can we help
hi i'm such an honor to talk to both of
you i'm a big fan thank you um
so
i am in baby step 2 and
i have recently decided that i think i
want to do a career change
and maybe go to a technical school to
become a software developer okay
and
obviously not doing any loans for that
i'm going to cash flow it but i'm
wondering if i should kind of add that
into my debt snowball since it will make
me more money once i'm done or if i
should wait until i'm debt-free what do
you mean by added to the debt snowball
just kind of like cash flow that to get
it started and then
um
but you said you're cash flowing
therefore you're not going into debt
yeah it's just the way she's describing
it so she's working her debt snowball
she wants to know should she cash flow
this technical training because it's
going to make a lot more money how much
money is it gonna cost you
i'm thinking somewhere between four to
eight thousand okay
and how much debt do you have
about thirteen thousand
what's your income currently
uh right at 50. awesome would you be
able to continue to make progress on on
the debt while cash flowing this
technical uh certification
i think so my expenses are pretty low so
i'm i've got quite a bit to work with as
far as um my debt snowball goes
and i don't know exactly how it works if
i have to pay all of it up front or if
it would be like kind of a you know
maybe make a payment of to get started
and make payments as i'm in it i don't
really know i haven't done that much
research yet okay but i don't think that
it should put me any farther that behind
and maybe like
a month
did cash flow to school
yeah no i'm sorry it will probably not
put me behind any more than two months
okay well my a1 is going to be cash
flowing this program if you are for
certain that it's going to increase your
income on the other side as soon as
you're done
to spend this four to eight thousand
dollars and so if you need to pause the
debt snowball temporarily while you get
through school debt free i'm all for
that
okay yep i would agree
you know it's just like we have people
that stand on this debt-free stage all
the time and tell us how much debt they
paid off and how many months and this is
while cash flowing other things so you
can move through the debt and cash flow
other important things this is as
important as it gets but do your
homework do your homework on this uh to
make sure you know what's the what the
payment situation looks like tell them
you're gonna pay cash maybe they give
you a discount for paying cash even if
you're cash flowing and kind of going on
a monthly basis but yeah go forward full
steam ahead on this i love that decision
i love that decision
let's get to jasmine if we can in
atlanta georgia jasmine how can we help
hi how are you guys today we are doing
well how can we help you
good i will warn you guys i'm a little
nervous that's okay don't be scared you
sound great already so go for it
perfect
thanks so um i just need help with
figuring out what to do next um so my
husband and i we've moved into his
parents house with our two children to
save money and pay off debt
but now that we've moved in we realized
that it wasn't a good idea
yeah
and so we need help figuring out what to
do next um we have a car that we'd like
to sell
but we you know after selling it i think
we would only have about 3 000 after
paying the loan
um
we have
hold on hold on hold on one
i want george to get on the money thing
real quick we got about two and a half
minutes but what's going on with we've
been there a couple months and we know
it's not a good idea now what's the
tension there
um it's a little toxic there's a lot of
like yelling and just
they have two other my husband has two
younger siblings
there's a lot of yelling with them and
stuff and i just don't want my kids to
be in that environment it's a lot
stressful for me as well does your
husband agree with that
yes he does agree okay well what they're
doing he doesn't agree but he also wants
to leave but the thing is we don't have
anything saved to move out so we don't
really know what to do
our household income is one hundred and
six thousand
so for a hundred six thousand dollars
could you not rent somewhere reasonable
and keep it at around a quarter of your
take-home pay
uh well we have nothing saved and we are
paying them rent as well why do you have
to have something saved i'm talking
about using your future paychecks to pay
for rent yeah
oh i mean yeah i guess we could do that
i mean we're looking for places to live
and you know they do ask for
you know like first last and you know
security which we don't have any of that
right now but you could you could within
a month right
i guess that's true yes you gotta do
anything like with my
yeah i would use this toxicity as fuel
to stack up as much cash as possible and
get out of this thing and yes sell the
car if it's worth more than the loan you
said you'll net three thousand dollars
yes what other debt do you have you kind
of need a car too
school loans and just credit cards
stuff like that okay well with the with
the profits you have left over you're
going to get a beater car for now do you
have is this the only car you have as a
family
yes okay
so i'd stack up some cash you may not be
able to do it for three thousand dollars
so stack up some cash in the meantime
then your next job is going to be to
stack up cash to get out of there and
rent somewhere reasonable as you start
to pay off this debt
okay you can do this jasmine you may
have to put up with it for another 30 or
60 days max
but if you get as george says get a pair
of nose noise canceling headphones
that'll help with the yelling that's a
good call
that's an idea get the kids out of the
house for a while i mean there's a way
to avoid this and give yourself enough
ramp up time to be able to move out and
move out well you guys can do this
you're so close way to go
oh boy sounds like we got some monster
in laws ooh that's a guy i've never
heard that one before it's a great movie
you should watch it with whitney
sometime hey i want to thank george
campbell always fun kyle i want to thank
our team behind the glass for all they
do we want to thank you america because
this
is your show it is
the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life
by talking about your money your work
and your relationships i'm ken coleman
joined by george campbell this hour
we're taking your calls it's a free
phone call triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you warmed up george
are you ready to go i'm pumped yeah it's
friday and i'm with kenny coleman i know
it's a good day it's a good day we were
just talking during the break uh
both of our wives are out of town we may
just carry the show uh to a local uh pub
or a happy hour we might we might just
take this advice to the happy hour can
we broadcast it live for the people i
don't think kelly would want to do that
but uh she's not trying to hang out with
us that doesn't make her happy you see
what i'm saying i see what i just did
there we'll find other friends other
friends all right there it is all right
let's get to the phones hunter is up
next in los angeles california hunter
how can we help
thanks guys taking my call how you doing
today we are having a blast what's going
on
hey so i'm getting married in a couple
weeks on june 11th hey congratulations
thank you thank you we're young we're 21
so we're excited hey listen i was 23
when i got married you'll figure it out
young love you got this
that's great um so basically my question
is uh i feel like we're kind of set up
right now but i just want to make sure
that we're setting ourselves up long
term
so i just we need uh advice on how to be
wise with our finances in the future and
how not to screw up what we already have
well now tell us what you mean by
you feel like you're already set up what
does that mean
is there a trust fund involved
no trust fund but i think we're doing
all right so
right now our before tax income is going
to be
115 000. nice wow
um yeah we both just graduated school so
we're super excited about that too you
already got jobs lined up
yeah yeah so i'll be a civil engineer
and she'll be an elementary school
teacher and no and no debt
uh no debt
wow well you are set up nicely
so so what's your question for us then
yeah so her parents my future in-laws
are setting us up with a
150 000 lump sum whoa and yeah
make sure we're doing that right well
first thing you want to do is think
about what gifts you're going to send
george and i for the stellar advice
we're about right now
man you're flush with cash this is
awesome okay do you have any money in
the bank currently
yeah i think our combined savings is
somewhere around 12 000 outside of the
lump sum okay spectacular great so you
kind of have i'm guessing a starter
emergency fund may be close to fully
funded three to six months of expenses
yeah are you guys renting when you get
married
yeah so we're looking for apartments
right now so we'll move in once we get
married
awesome great okay so you're asking how
do you set yourselves up for success
i think you're already a sharp young
dude at 21 years old you already have
money you have this wonderful gift from
the in-laws and so i want you to steward
that well so i would look at what are
our next goals as a couple sit down
together and maybe it's a nice date
night maybe on the honeymoon you start
dreaming a little bit of what life looks
like
and go all right are we good on cars do
you guys have decent cars that get you
around
yeah so that's the one thing we need her
car's fine but my car i got a old beat
up toyota that needs to be replaced okay
so maybe we upgrade that to something
reasonable let's not get crazy
because the rest of the money i really
want you to have that as a down payment
on your first home together
now i don't want you to rush into that i
suggest waiting rent for a year get to
know each other get settled into married
life start to look around work with a
real estate agent and start to go where
do we want to live how much is it going
to be and when you do that do a 15-year
fixed with as much down as possible and
let the payment be no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay and then
aggressively pay that off are you guys
planning to stay in los angeles
uh so we're actually in central
california oh so we're a little bit
north of there okay cool so you got a
good idea what housing looks like out
there
yeah it's much more i mean the house uh
and where we're at about half what it is
in los angeles honestly okay good it
sounds like you guys are on the same
page financially about your values
already
that's a wonderful thing yeah i think
this is great well we'll give you a
wedding gift of
one year of ramsay plus includes
financial peace university every dollar
premium would that be fun for you
oh that's awesome yeah we would love
that guidance for sure i think that will
give you some ideas and some inspiration
some motivation along this journey as
you start off your life together if you
watch those videos and start doing an
every dollar budget because what can
happen is you're a newlywed couple
you start to go we have jobs now we can
start to have some fun start to live our
life so i want you to balance your
short-term goals with the long-term
goals so the long-term goal might be we
want to get in a house about three years
from now we're going to keep stacking up
cash to have a great down payment but we
also want to go on vacation when we
upgrade the car yeah you know it's okay
to enjoy it too you guys have done
really well at 21. great head start and
when did you say the wedding was the
wedding is uh june 11th george what's
your calendar look like i'm free i
happen to be free ken george listen he's
going to charge you a little bit so i
would suggest considering some of the
150 000 going to george for him to be
the wedding singer he's he's he's wildly
uh he's wildly entertaining
with his little guitar up there and i do
mean little not a little good it's a
normal sized guitar oh it just looks a
little or with you that hurts but i have
been hired before for the record yeah
yeah and i'll congratulate i'm really
not trying to pawn george off on you but
he's a wonderful wonderful singer so
there you go hey hunter you guys are off
to a great start man this is super
exciting uh for to hear about a young
couple and can we just
can we just slow clap for the mom and
dad who are in a position to be able to
uh give them a 150 000 head start i mean
what what a legacy how about blessing
while they're alive they're leaving a
legacy wow unbelievable that's
incredible george are you can you get in
another call in two and a half minutes
uh
sure
terry you're up in manchester new
hampshire terry hawkins
terry
hi thanks for taking my call i have a
question um i'm about three years from
being able to take my full service
retirement um through my employer in a
school system okay and i i reached out
for information about if i could make
additional contributions to boost my
pension amount and they came back to me
and said with only three years left i
could do that and it would be about
fourteen thousand dollars a year for the
next three years that i could add into
what i'm already contributing okay and
i'm just wondering if it makes sense to
do that or to invest that [ __ ]
somewhere else well what is that going
to amount to in the payments in the
pension
so it would amount to an extra six
thousand dollars a year that i would get
in my pension for the rest of my life
six thousand a year
yeah okay so i do the math and i go all
right that's 42 that you're putting in
um six thousand so it takes seven years
to to roi on this decision
okay does that feel good to you
i'm not sure how old are you i'm 57
you're 57. personally i don't think it's
worth it because i think if you invested
42 000
i think that money is going to be much
bigger money down the line
okay
that's why i was calling because i don't
know how to articulate all that math in
my head so thank you what's the total
pension per month
that you're looking at currently
so currently would be about 46 000 and
this would visit to 52. okay can you
live off that 46 000 plus a year plus
your retirement do you have anything
else in retirement
um i don't
and
one of my ideas by retiring at 60 is
because that could allow me to jump over
to the other state nearby and work
full-time and start on another pension
ah okay that's not a bad idea yeah i
just make sure you can live off whatever
the pension's going to be and that you
feel good about that that's definitely
part of the plan thanks for the call
yeah very exciting
by the way she's 57 years young
point good good good pointer see there
george saved us all he asked a woman how
old she i'm sorry it's part of the job
it's it's still
chivalry still must be applied george
fair point i'm working on him folks
don't move more ramsey show coming right
up
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me as we
take your calls this hour triple eight
eight two five
five two two five george the housing
market over the last couple of years has
obviously been bonkers yes that's one
way of saying it very unique right
home prices that keep going up up up
hungry buyers or and were pouncing on
homes as soon as they hit the market but
now there's a bit of a plot twist the
federal reserve is up the ante the
federal funds rate have been raised for
the first time in three years and now
mortgage rates are going to go up too
and that's got a lot of people out there
including those of you listening
watching today a little bit worried that
higher mortgage rates or maybe even a
recession might make buying and selling
more difficult so first of all let's all
take a breath
turn off the news and get some
perspective a whole lot goes into buying
and selling a home
not just market conditions and mortgage
rates so
anytime you're looking to buy or sell
you got to do homework and team up with
a pro who actually knows what they're
doing
so if you want more info on how the fed
works why this interest rate hike
happened and what you can do about it
head over to ramseysolutions.com
rates that's ramsey solutions.com
rates you can also go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent to talk to one of our world-class
endorsed local providers
uh in that program these ramsey trusted
real estate agents know how to handle
market changes and they'll help you
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
agent all right back to the phones we go
triple eight eight two five
five two two five william joins us in
columbia missouri william how can we
help
hey george can't wish all a blessed
weekend um recently divorced and as part
of the divorce settlement and separation
of marital assets
um we need to figure out what to do with
the house and i gave my ex the option to
buy it and give me a payout of equity
she did not do that and so now i have
the option to buy the house and give her
a split of the equity
so she doesn't want the house
she does want it she just didn't
refinance it
i do have some money you know the
emergency fund a little bit of cash and
everything but not enough to cover the
equity and so i'm looking at
um
doing a refinance or a heloc or
something
i don't have any other debt um i've got
my cars that i could take out a title on
but i know all those things are very
anti-ramsey yeah the only thing i would
suggest in your situation is a cash out
refinance i would not do a heloc
okay so if you refinance it you take the
amount you need out of there to pay her
and be done with it now would you
qualify for that with your income
uh i believe so um but even with the
increased rates and the
loan origination fees and all that it's
not a super high value home and so those
fees
make a pretty sizable percent of
you know what i'd be getting i mean can
we just let go of the house yeah i'm
wondering can we sell it
be done with it i
well we could um
it's the only house my kids have lived
in
that's okay
i've lived in multiple homes i've lived
i survived it let me let me say this and
i hear your heart
liam i hear that
um
and i don't want to add insult to injury
here but i want to be really honest with
you
these kids are going to go through and
and are going through more trauma as it
relates to the divorce than the issue of
the home where they live
it will not the them moving to another
place where they haven't lived is not
going to impact them anywhere near as
badly as the divorce and i'm not saying
that to make you feel bad i'm just
simply saying right that's not something
that would hold me up
right it seems like this is the best
move financially if we remove the
emotional attachment is selling the
house the best financial move for you
right now
yes
as an aside and
um
my
my
sorry that's okay we're here take your
time man
uh
my oldest has been
struggling yeah
and uh
attempted suicide yesterday oh my
goodness william i'm so sorry
what's the situation as it stands right
now are they in a hospital are they with
you what's going on
yeah she's in the hospital
oh
is this uh something that she was
struggling with prior to the divorce or
is this divorce related
well
with uh
kovid the divorce stretched out several
years
and uh
it
she's been having
difficulty since she was
10
yeah
what's her health situation right now as
far as being in the hospital is she
going to be okay physically after this
attempt
um
yes there's no
permanent damage
but then
i don't know what the
psychological yeah
well this is going to be yeah this is an
ongoing battle that um you're in the
midst of
what's the urgency with the house
situation do you need to make a decision
soon um i've got three months
okay so
let's for a moment
you need as much
mental capacity and financial
flexibility as possible right now is
that correct
right so
what was your plan uh if you were to
sell the house would you just rent an
apartment
what would you do
um
i would like to
buy something and
you know
make it home yeah i know you'd like to
but how much do you stand to make let's
just look at the numbers here for a
second because this is important with
the yeah the truth
it's uh
probably around 30 to 40 total equity in
it
total it's a
total yeah how much would you how much
would you have to give to your ex-wife
15.
so you're going to walk away with 15.
right
do you have any money right now in the
bank
um i've got
uh
2 000 cash i've got 12 000 in the bank
okay
good
so do you have any debt currently
other than the
mortgage no okay that's great great news
because
you and your ex-wife i i i hope are in
some type of alignment that you got to
do everything you can to fight for your
baby girl right
not at all
it is very
very little cooperation
in anything
okay what's the custody situation
um
i
get the girls for a week she gets the
girls for a week
okay
so
here's the deal um we would love to line
you up to talk to dr john deloney if
that's something you're comfortable with
because you're going through a lot of
stuff right now and you need as much
clarity as possible so
if that's something you want when we put
you on hold in the moment we'll get you
lined up but here here's george here's
where i'm at
um william i don't want you thinking
about buying another place right now
you are debt free that's the good news
in this situation that you have no
financial debt as another stressor and
an anxiety driver in the midst of this
situation you're going through with your
daughter not to mention your own pain
and the other children's pain
i wouldn't be thinking about buying
anything right now i would be just
socking things away yeah keeping your
head above water in your work to keep
bringing in money safe safe safe let the
dust settle the health professionals the
mental health professionals are going to
get together on your daughter and then
hopefully there's going to be a path of
healing forward for her and that's going
to cost some money yeah william could
you scrape together the 15 to pay her
you almost have it
um
i like i say i could but that would
totally wipe out any emergency fund and
everything like that
well this i look at this almost as a
debt and so if you can clear this
without having to refi and go through
like you mentioned all the fees
origination i think it's a cleaner break
if you can save up some money in the
next few months and keep the house and
still have a few thousand in the bank
is that what you're saying george keep
the house keep the currency keep the
house for now and that way when you do
sell it if you choose to do so down the
line because i think right now the a1 is
the health of these children and the
safety of these children the house to me
is it's just an asset we'll deal with
that later
william here's the deal hang on the line
uh kelly and the team are gonna pick you
up we've got some great resources for
you we'll get you connected to dr
deloney as well uh if you'd like to talk
with him on the air and get some advice
on your health your daughter's health as
well
mental health so please call us back if
we can help in any other way man so
sorry you're going through this so very
sorry hearts are broken for you william
[Music]
fight for your family fight hard for
your precious daughter this is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
let's let that play for a second
[Music]
can't beat tom petty george
i'm pretty sure our podcast and youtube
it's all different music so what they're
going to say though
someone in the booth tell me all right
do they all hear the same music wherever
they listen
sorry it's different if you want to
listen to the radio show and hear the
music sometimes the team does a great
great bumps great bumps you know we
can't do that anymore because
everybody's got to get their little
license they got to get a piece of that
they can't write a song for the world to
enjoy gotta get paid i'm gonna start
writing my own music for the show ken
custom with you
put a ukulele in a kazoo we'll just do
our own bumps
kelly said no kelly kelly's had enough
there will be no ukulele she said no
ukulele for you a little ukulele it's
very whimsical i think it's actually
fantastic i think it could work but hey
i'm okay with the ukulele it's more the
kazoo i have an issue with you know what
i would agree with that fair point so i
could just sit over here and watch you
george instead of trying to chime in but
we had one caller recently say that they
would love to hear me sing some ricky
martin i think it was a dark curiosity
yeah well i think it was a compliment it
will go it will go unquenched because
i'm not singing ricky martin ever not
even like at the house and that is
called a blessing yeah so thank you
fantastic all right atlanta georgia is
where we go next kevin is there kevin
how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
bet what's up um so so yeah the big
problem we're trying to figure out is we
are moving in a month we've been at this
house for about two years
we renovated it and we're about to sell
it
we just finished paying off about 70 000
in student loans so we have no debt wait
thank you
uh we've been working hard
we have about 15 000 in savings
plus about 50 000 and 401k
um we'll be making about 120 000 profit
on this house and we're wondering what
to do with the profit and so in our
heads we're thinking three options
either rent an apartment
buy a house and rent it out a year later
to buy another house with or just go
ahead and buy
a long-term home
and we just never sold a house before
and we don't know what to do with this
profit so that's kind of where we're at
well you definitely have options so
where are you moving to
moving from atlanta to chattanooga
tennessee okay
well i would rent for now
as you get acclimated to the area and
figure out what's going on and let the
market do its thing yep maybe cool off a
little bit and park that money that 120
000 in a high-yield savings account high
yield is a hilario it's just a term but
it's probably about one percent right
now if you're lucky and i'm okay with
that because you said you're planning on
probably buying a property in the next
year
right so we don't want to throw that
money in the stock market and it
continues to go down and your 120 just
turned into 90 and now you need to buy a
house
yes so that's why i'm parking in a kind
of a boring savings account for now as
you figure out what your next steps are
yeah and i'm curious to know you said
one of the options you mentioned well
maybe we buy another house and then rent
that i mean what kind of kind of prices
are we talking about what are you
looking at financially because we don't
want you to get over leveraged
right about um our price transit is
about two to three hundred thousand okay
good cool so you'd have a nice healthy
down payment i would only go with a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage and make
sure that payment is no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay what's
your income
50 000 is that total household income
um currently we're looking into some
more options but that's currently it
yeah okay cool well that's gonna be my
plan park that money use it as a down
payment on the next house are there any
upgrades you guys have to do do you need
to park some of that for moving costs
um
yeah probably a little bit okay so do
what you need to do there make it
reasonable make sure that we don't touch
that emergency fund is that 15k
basically your emergency fund you got it
okay make sure to separate that out i
would not leave them in the same account
because all of a sudden you know all the
cookies in the cookie jar start to look
the same so park that money aside only
for true emergencies that means it's
urgent necessary and unexpected
which means moving is not one of those
moving is not an emergency and that
buying a house is also not an emergency
yeah yeah you're doing great man that's
a good problem to have yeah and i i
would second george what you said i
think it's really important for people
certainly young couples
you're moving from one city to another
take a year
minimum of rent i mean we don't think
renting is a sin around here people
think it's throwing money away i think
it's buying yourself patience buying
yourself some time to make a wise
decision i love that get some
perspective you know get an idea you're
moving to a new city so from atlanta to
chattanooga that's a whole different
world there's enough to acclimate to
yeah alone hvac went out all of a sudden
exactly don't be itching to you know
spend this money for an investment as
opposed to going what's the right house
the right location i mean because you
and i were talking during the break i
mean
i mean we've both benefited as have
millions of americans of these rising
home prices but buying in the right
neighborhood in the right place is a
bigger benefit than other places and and
you know it's thinking in calls kind of
people buying sight unseen with no
inspection or appraisal and all of a
sudden they're in a money pit because it
needs a new roof and the foundation's
cracking and they just got into it out
of impulse yeah it's it's completely
absurd and you you could make a purchase
thinking oh it looks good you know of
all the factors and then you get
yourself trapped and freedom meaning i
don't have to have a mortgage i don't
have to lock into something i mean
that's that's a good thing yeah that's
that's a really good people they get on
to us ken for our parameters around
housing we say the only mortgage we're
not going to yell you for is a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage with the payment
being no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay and people go that might
have worked in the 80s ken dave but that
doesn't work in today's market and the
truth is
it does work yeah i did it it may just
mean you need to take more time you need
to save up for two or three more years
all right now this is down payment so we
were talking about this recently all the
personalities dave we were in the room
we were talking about this we are in a
really extraordinary time
where for many people
the housing market is still too hot now
we're starting to see
uh
some cracks if you will so signs that so
the pressure is relieving a little bit
and and housing prices might slow down
but not regress
but you've got people that are listening
and watching right now george who are
they're saying simply put
george are you telling me i got to wait
two years three years four years i i
can't
afford to do the 15 year i just can't do
it right now what do you say to those
people um i tell them you can't afford
to be a homeowner and that's not me
being a jerk that's just me wanting them
to win financially because i know we
also get calls and people go we got into
the house and we're house poor we can't
achieve any of our goals
we can't save for retirement we can't
send the kids that we can't save for
college we can't go on vacations because
we're too tight
we have no money in savings we're in
this big old mortgage yeah and we have
no way out and i don't want that for him
and so i want you to be house poor and
if that means now i'm not saying you
need to pay cash for your house i'm not
people go oh you want us to wait 20
years to say but no i'm saying save up 5
10 15 20 down yeah on a reasonable house
have a different picture of what that
first home may look like for you
especially first first-time home buyers
and then you go okay
what is it going to take to get there
well it means we got to get out of debt
we need an emergency fund then we're
starting to save up for the down payment
well and let's also talk about
the factors that can help you accelerate
this process yes housing prices are high
inflation is high
but
so are incomes right now that's right
and so we talk to people all the time
well i feel like i'm limited why do you
feel limited well i want to live in this
area well
what's more important
living in this area
or being able to get that house or to
get that job that you want to make the
money so is the job more important is
the professional advancement more
important than the type of house you
live in
see sometimes you have to make choices
folks
and and if you are advancing in your
career professionally and it requires
that you pay your dues whatever that
looks like and part of paying your dues
is is that i've got to get here in
position x for company abc whatever to
be able to advance to where i want to be
listen folks five years 10 years 15
years down the line then that means i
can't maybe it's not a good decision to
buy a house right now or maybe i get
something that's or i live further out
whatever i've got to do
to get where i want to go
is what we do not well i want the house
plus i want the great job well i want a
lamborghini george can't do that i
really do i drove one i like time and
then what sacrifices are you willing to
make to get there time that's right and
by the way it's not even willing to make
right now i got three teens
i can't make the sacrifices and you
can't afford to feed them yeah boy
that's we're switching to turkey bacon
is that really it it's really a thing
wow
not great i've had turkey bacon i'm
always choosing the pork just me hey
don't move much more important issues
still to come this is the ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
camel so glad that you are with us our
scripture of the day comes from job 17
verse 9. nevertheless the righteous will
hold to their ways and those with clean
hands will grow stronger
our quote of the day comes from beau
schembeckler boy i don't know if
somebody just teed this up for me or not
legendary michigan coach
will were you behind this no he can't
take credit every day you either get
better or you get worse you never stay
the same all right nice i'm a big
michigan fan i'm sure there's always
some buckeye out there that gets
offended when i say that there wasn't
enough money in the world for me to know
who that was ken so i'm glad you're here
[Laughter]
i wouldn't have been able to pronounce
the last name let alone guess it was a
michigan coach fair but you know how to
play a ukulele so i can't do that we all
have ourselves so see we all have our
roles and our strengths uh
so i wanted to share a feel-good story
if i might you know there's so much you
can use that right now is that right so
much of the news
uh in today's world
um
it's so negative it's designed to get
your attention it's designed to get your
click to scare you to get you to dive in
more
and uh i i shared a story earlier today
on the ken coleman show about three
companies uh two of which you'd know the
names easily the other one you might not
one is amazon of course and of course
they get beat up all the time big bad
evil amazon some people think they're
evil you know who knows
walgreens
one of the stalwart you know
pharmacy type companies in our country
and then wawa which is a regional gas
station
convenience store are you a wawa yeah
fun to say fun to visit yeah big in the
northeast i think
and the headline it was from cnbc but
the headline was basically that
these three companies in particular
are
are winning the war on their employment
issues so we've got this big employment
gap in the united states that everything
everybody's pretty aware of where we've
got more jobs available than people who
are unemployed it's what's driven up you
know salaries and hourly rates so these
three companies are looking to
a group of people
who have some form of neuro disabilities
who are
overwhelmingly
unemployed in fact 85 percent of people
with those issues or challenges
are
unemployed george wow and the reason is
and the article points this out is
because it takes some accommodations
not a lot
but some accommodations for these men
and women
some young teenagers
young 20s to be able to come into your
workplace and do a good job but whether
it be warehousing stocking shelves
whatever
walgreens specifically has done an
incredible job
so you take kids with autism so one in
45 male 1 in 45 adults is on the autism
spectrum
which is pretty fascinating when you
think a big chunk of people and i got to
tell you i read this article and i was
so fired up in a good way
because you think number one there's an
employment gap where these men and women
can be given an opportunity to
do something valuable
make a living
and and
receive the benefit of that george
and you think of the burden that it is
for so many families who may have a
family member who struggle with this and
the opportunity to get out and be
gainfully employed and to live a life
and they can be effective
and and as i was reading the article
there you know again several quotes in
this but we're talking one or two
accommodations walgreens has actually
hired a uh outside firm that coaches
these men and women
so that they learn the job that's cool
and they become and here's what happens
the attrition rate
and the you know
the amount of people who leave in these
positions is very very low and so
retention is higher wow and you just
think of so many men and women who need
a chance and there is an opportunity
here if leaders
would just be willing
to deal with the uncomfortableness maybe
some you know asperger's syndrome or
something so what so there's some
awkwardness there's awkwardness
all the time
and george i gotta tell you it really
warmed my heart because these men and
women deserve the opportunity to
contribute to the world and make a
living as well and and and so amazon
training these these men and women
um basic accommodations
and a little bit of coaching and it's
really really working now on top of that
the
purpose that it gives people sure to
throw themselves into some work that has
meaning there that i don't know if
that's quantifiable well at a soul level
of what it does to go i'm needed yeah in
the world i have an impact to make right
no matter what it is i don't care if
you're you know a surgeon or a walmart
greeter there's immense purpose in all
types of work yeah and so many different
types of people who they use the word
disability and understand why
but instead of looking them as disabled
what if we looked at them as differently
abled you know i i've got a dear friend
who
who uh
has two down syndrome children
and i don't know if you've ever spent
time with someone who is down cinder but
immense joy
there's no more joy on this side of
heaven and you know i think if you've
got a business where you want a greeter
i'd be hiring those fine folks to greet
people because of the joy the love they
just warm everybody's heart and and
everybody can do something
even if it's the most menial of task
well a lot of people don't want to do
menial tasks or if they take the job
doing the menial task they quickly want
to be promoted but these men and women
who have some neuro challenges and
things of that nature they can
absolutely be
fulfilled i mean like
joy is stocking the shelves
and so
there is an opportunity so i just wanted
to tell you we hear a lot of negative
news about big companies like amazon or
walgreens or where but these companies
are seeing an opportunity and i think
that this is available for small
businesses as well to say hey i'm having
a hard time getting people in hey you're
a restaurant and you're having a hard
time staffing
uh
a host or hostess that's where i'm going
somebody with a smile who can greet
somebody and lead them to a table wow
well ken i saw another article this
morning and it was very of course
fear-mongering and it was the job
market's very everyone's very
pessimistic about the job market it went
on to say well there's actually two jobs
for every one american but people are
very pessimistic about the job market
it's ridiculous what what's at the heart
of all of this yeah are people just not
satisfied in their work
well
you mean all the job hopping everything
it's just a pessimism around well here's
a lot of pessimism around work in
general yeah well the so there's two
schools of thought
one business leaders business owners
they don't like this big gap
because it's driving up salaries in
hourly rates
so when you it's a supply demand issue
so when the supply of jobs is
very wide the gap between how many
people unemployed that drives up
costs in the form of salaries you ready
for this the fed the fed our friends
over at the fed are they our friends i
don't think so it was tongue-in-cheek
they're trying to convince
the biggest corporations in america to
go on a voluntary hiring freeze
the reason yes that's how i react i'm
confused by that because they think it's
going to help with inflation
so people are leaving jobs you've heard
this the great resignation we've had
nearly 40 million people leave jobs
wouldn't more workers stimulate the
economy yes but these morons at the fed
think that if we do a temporary hiring
fees first of all
who who do they think they are to tell
private companies
no of course they can't but they're
asking nicely
but that is so absurd
and nonsensical because they're going
well that's going to help stem the tide
of inflation because one of the major
drivers of inflation let's make no
mistake about it is in fact the increase
in salaries because if i've got to pay a
kid at taco bell
three dollars more an hour well trust me
you're gonna see that in your chalupa
i never thought i'd hear that sentence
today it's a brand new one for me yeah
yeah well we were just at a local
restaurant last night and there were
there was a 45 minute wait and i looked
around there's empty tables everywhere
and i'm no wait i don't i'm confused
they had about three people running the
whole show right and so there's a severe
labor shortage and a lot of work to be
done
and i i think it some of it stems from
people going well i don't want to do
that and i'm going to find something
else to do i'm going to find another
that's their right by the way i mean you
know i
look
you can have different schools of
thought on this but a sign of a healthy
capitalistic economy
there's always going to be a bit of a
gap it shouldn't be as big as it is now
but you're always in a healthy economy
you're going to have more jobs available
than people you want low unemployment
true
so anyway all that to say
um
you know where my heart can though about
all that there was a server there and
she said hey are you do you
are you think i know yeah she said i
just finished the high school curriculum
in personal finance come on she's a
junior come on crushing it and she
called me sir and i went wow
that is the kind of respect i've been
needing around here yeah so mad respect
you so she finally called you sir and
that makes you happy
whereas i don't want to be called sir so
there you go i'm still young enough
it warms my heart gave you a little more
stature yes no pun intended hey george
campbell fun stuff today i want to thank
kelly the entire team behind the glass
and you america this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you